my basic explanation of what I generally
call IT I think there are several
components to IT but the vast majority
of what I would call a key it could be
summed up with rhythm and timing so I'm
going to use a non Aikido analogy here
and something we're all very familiar
with in school when someone goes to sit
down in the chair and as they sit you
pulled the chair out from under them
like you essentially throw them right
you're throwing them this is something
we're all familiar with there's nothing
mystical or magical about it we've all
seen it in school in order for me to do
this though I have to create an IT
relationship with my partner my partner
so as Mike stands in front of chair he's
basically gonna go through a procedure
he's gonna look to see if there's a
chair there and then once he's confident
that there's a chair there he's gonna
begin the rhythm of sitting okay this is
his sitting rhythm okay my job is the
one who wants to make a 90 interaction
with him and make him fall down is to
notice when he is in the sitting rhythm
and as soon as he's comfortable and goes
to sit down I see good remove the chair
and he falls it's very easy
so if before if I'm not being 90 with
Mike and I'm ahead of mine when my
and I Muhammad blow up the chair what's
not gonna sit down because I pulled up
the chair yeah Mike's not in the sitting
room he's being cautious right or
actually it might be it's down before uh
before I get a chance to pull away from
it's locked down I can't get the chair
out from right now maybe I can use
muscle or something to get him out of my
good body alignment I can tip Mike out
of the chair but it might sit down
before he a chance to pull it out
I wasn't being very nice it likes being
cautious and thinks that I'm going to
trick him Michael be very careful hold
on and I really won't get the rhythm see
Mike's following the chair right I can't
get it out from under because Mike is
paying attention to the chair so what I
have to do in order to make an IP
relation with Mike and isn't make him
fall down is make sure he's in a sitting
rhythm
as soon as he is I pull it out from
under he can't help it because he's gone
into the rhythm of sitting as soon as I
recognized the rhythm I removed the
chair and he falls on the ground
I used Mike's idea of what's happening
against him
my explanation of Mikey